i still hear from many many women i made
this point and it wasn't until one of
the men around the table
you know made the point that actually
somebody went yeah that's a great idea
why don't we do that
for decades women have struggled to have
their voices heard in the city
but slowly britain's biggest companies
are changing
when boardrooms are occupied once more
for the first time more than a third of
all the seats at the 350
largest listed firms will be occupied by
female directors
denise wilson spent her career at the
top of british business and has led a
review
that has driven a 50 increase in female
directors
in five years despite a sometimes
hostile culture
i think the thing that is most disabling
is the
build-up of those micro-behaviors over
time
and the toll that they can have in just
grinding people down
and that is why we see a lot of people
give up in the workplace
i think we've made tremendous progress
and the initiative and the voluntary
business-led approach which the uk has
adopted
is working very well for business since
2015 the proportion of women on the
boards of the 350 largest listed
companies
has risen from 21.9 to 34.3 percent
in the same period the number of
companies with women occupying a third
of board seats rose from 53 to 220
but 64 of leadership roles or two out of
every three
still go to men and top jobs remain an
overwhelmingly male domain
in ftse 350 companies just 17
have a female chief executive progress
on tackling the gender gap at the top
comes as the pandemic has revealed
inequalities borne by women
working in the worst affected sectors
having companies overwhelmingly run by
men has always seemed self-defeating not
least because 50
of your potential customers and
employees will be women
so the fact a third of directors are now
female
is progress but it's a long way from
being representative
charlotte verler served on ftse 250
boards
she says this review needs to be a
staging post if we say
33 women do we say 67
men uh so i think what we need to do is
change the language
we need to get a lot closer to to to
what is parity
and and parity it's not always 50 50. if
you are
you know 11 people on the board for
example or seven people in a management
team then
we should go for minimum 40 maybe 45
either gender long-standing advocates
for female representation
say role models are crucial it matters
from a representation perspective
it matters from a role model perspective
when we look up within organizations we
need to see
people that look like us but i think
everybody needs to see
diverse um talent this isn't just
about female employees this is about
all employees seeing leaders that look
like them
that women can should and do lead is not
in question
providing more with the opportunity to
do so may require more
than just the city to change paul kelso
sky news